qui a tout nouveau produit qui vient de
faire son arrivée chez Marshall c'est ça
c'est l'ancien portable connecté
Middleton Middleton très chouette
nouvelle référence et d'ailleurs cette
nouvelle référence elle est juste là et
vous le voyez elle a un truc qui est
particulier c'est que vous avez une
bandoulière donc vous passez votre main
dedans tac tac tac tac comme ça vous la
prenez vous partez vous balader donc on
va regarder aujourd'hui parce que
raconte cette enceinte quels sont les
nouveautés qu'est-ce qu'elle vient faire
comment elle trouve sa place dans la
gamme est-ce qu'elle est intéressante
bref tout ça et on le fait tout de suite
[Musique]
ça c'est l'enceinte Middleton de
Marshall nouvelle enceinte connectée de
marche alors chez Marshall il y a pas
mal de produits j'en ai déjà présenté
énormément sur ma chaîne vous connaissez
son légende rock n' roll design iconique
et on retrouve une face plus ce design
ici directement chez Marshall avec cette
grande grille avec ce logo qui est là
qui est typé qui est joli avec ses
boutons avec des lumières à LED sur le
dessus je vais vous expliquer ce que ça
raconte dans quelques instants ça c'est
aussi très très chouette on retrouve des
grilles sur le côté pourquoi pour mettre
des haut-parleurs ben ouais vous allez
voir ça c'est une technologie signée
Marshall qui vous permet d'avoir du son
qui vient à 360 degrés de tous les côtés
c'est du son enveloppant très très
chouette déconnecté sur le dessous il y
a pas grand chose parce qu'il faut bien
que ça se pose quelque part et puis
cette espèce de grande lanière convient
prendre qu'on vient poser comme ça et
qui vous sert à venir le prendre allez
vous balader partout et surtout vous
voyez c'est solide ça tient c'est
pratique pourquoi parce que l'ADN de
cette enceinte Marshall et bien c'est de
sortir de chez vous c'est d'aller vous
balader alors effectivement la maison on
peut la prendre la poser sur un meuble
et se mettre de la musique très
facilement mais ce qu'on veut réellement
ici en fait c'est emmener la musique
partout avec soi tout le temps alors
regardez je vous un peu comment ça
marche cet enceinte vous avez quelques
petits boutons sur le dessus vous venez
l'appairer très facilement avec votre
smartphone vous appuyez longtemps ici
vous allez l'allumer vous allez
l'éteindre et lorsque vous l'éteignez et
que vous allumez vous avez le son
Marshall qu'on trouve à chaque fois sur
les enceintes connectées donc vous venez
faire ça ici et puis vous allez
retrouver regardez juste là en fait ça
c'est un play pose vous montez le son
vous avez votre petit voyant qui vous
permet de voir votre niveau on fait
gaffe sac à m'envoie un petit peu de son
morceau suivant morceau précédent donc
ça c'est l'aparté que ce grand bouton en
fait que vous venez piloter 360 qui
vachement cool mais vous avez également
sur le côté et venez voir ça ça me plaît
bien et bien vous avez des petits
boutons qui sont cachés complètement
cachés regardez directement intégré dans
le design et en fait c'est pour venir
régler votre équaliseur alors pas
réellement adéqualiseur mais vous pouvez
monter les basses ou les baisser et la
même chose avec les aigus donc vous les
avez vous avez qu'à appuyé ici et ce qui
est cool vous avez ici en plus un petit
vue mettre en rose c'est pas réellement
vu mettre ça vous permet de savoir où
vous en êtes au niveau des basses vous
pouvez les mettre au tacos les mettre en
bas c'est une graduation sur 10 niveaux
donc moi je la mets là pareil pour les
aigus donc ça c'est quand même choix et
donc ça vous permet de voir et bien
votre niveau de basse votre niveau
d'aigu votre volume bien évidemment mais
également votre niveau de batterie parce
que vous avez un petit bouton là qui
vous indique le niveau de batterie vous
voyez j'en ai je suis pas mal et là j'ai
un petit bouton pour le Bluetooth voilà
pour les boutons qu'on vient retrouver
ici c'est simple c'est clair ça marche
bien et ça c'est chouette on se parle
bien ici d'une enceinte nomade j'ai qu'à
la prendre alors moi aussi je prends mon
petit smartphone je mets de la musique
tac et voilà j'ai le son qui sort
directement de mon enceinte c'est facile
et puis je peux me balader une fois de
plus avec alors le truc est très cool
ici c'est que je peux effectivement
venir régler mes niveaux de base par
exemple je veux mettre des basses à fond
et baisser un peu mes aiguës je peux
venir le faire ça va envoyer de la basse
attention vous êtes prêts là ça envoie
de la basse à l'inverse si je veux venir
baisser les basses et monter et rajouter
un peu plus d'aiguille pour ramener plus
de clarté dans les médiums et les aigus
et ben je peux le faire et le truc qui
est très cool ici c'est qu'en fait il y
a une technologie qui est signée
Marshall qui vous permet d'envoyer du
son à 360 degrés qui va venir sortir de
l'arrière qui va sortir de l'avant mais
également des deux côtés cette
technologie elle s'appelle trousse
unique permet d'envoyer le son à 360
degrés autour de votre Enceinte Marshall
Middleton comment ça se passe une fois
de plus et bien ils ont fait un schéma
intérieur de votre enceinte qui permet
de venir positionner à différents
endroits les quatre haut-parleurs parce
que oui ici vous avez bien quatre
haut-parleurs vous avez donc en avoir un
sur la façade avant 1 sur l'arrière 1
ici sur le côté et un ici sur le côté on
se parle ici de deux haut-parleurs de 20
watts et de 2 haut-parleurs de 10 watts
et un amplificateur de classe D comme ça
vous savez tout et cette solution est
intéressante pourquoi parce que comme on
vous parle d'une enceinte nomade que
vous prenez que vous partez vous balader
avec et bien lorsque je vais remettre de
la musique je sais que j'aurais du son
tous les côtés et ça c'est vachement
bien c'est vachement bien pourquoi bah
c'est vachement bien parce que vous
n'êtes pas toujours avec l'ensemble
devant vous et vous écoutez pas comme si
vous y êtes dans un concert non lorsque
vous êtes en ventre pote et bien vous
prenez votre enceinte vous la poser à un
endroit et vous allez faire l'apéro vous
allez boire un coup vous allez vous
amuser vous allez jouer bref vous allez
vivre autour de votre enceinte et le son
doit rayonner autour donc ça ça
vachement bien ça permet de le faire
effectivement avec cette techno mais
alors là où Marshall est malin et va
plus loin c'est qu'ils ont développé une
autre techno c'est la fonction stack qui
vous permet d'appairer différentes
enceintes Marshall entre elles pour
pouvoir maximiser l'expérience je vous
montre comment ça marche je vais
récupérer par exemple dans mon placard
ici une des enceintes Marshall on va se
prendre 2 et celle là elle est très cool
parce qu'elle permet effectivement aussi
d'utiliser la fonction stack c'est à
dire de mettre la musique que j'ai ici
de la mettre là alors comment ça se
passe déjà je vais commencer par mettre
un petit peu de musique là alors je vais
baisser le son parce que j'ai pas envie
de vous arracher les oreilles je viens
allumer ma deuxième enceinte pour mon
numberpone 2 que je vous ai présenté sur
ma chaîne youtube allez jeter un petit
coup d'œil parce qu'elle est aussi très
pratique c'est normal mais c'est pas le
même nomade c'est pas le même nomadisme
ça c'est du nomade de main vous baladez
ça va vous avez la sangle elle est quand
même beaucoup plus lourde faut dire que
le son on fera un peu plus fatalement
sans doutera ce que je fais ici je vais
dans mon application parce que oui bien
évidemment j'ai une application ça c'est
vachement bien je vais dans mon
application Marshall et dans mon
application Marshall j'ai effectivement
ma Middleton qui est connecté et là je
viens sur le mode stack je clique sur le
mode stack donc là je peux venir
commencer ma session est-ce que j'ai
entendu le son oui j'ai entendu le son
je vais ajouter une enceinte appuyez
deux fois sur le bouton Bluetooth pour
ajouter une enceinte j'entends le son je
clique sur entendu bon je peux venir
tester en appuyant là
donc là j'ai le son de tous les côtés ça
veut donc dire que maintenant lorsque je
vais remettre de la musique ici et bien
je l'ai également ici alors je vais vous
le montrer la preuve vous voyez je sur
le micro si je l'enlève je mets celle-là
j'ai le son de tous les côtés et donc là
ça vient prolonger mon expérience je
viens d'arrêter sur mon enceinte maître
celle qui pilote le bouzin et en fait ce
qui est génial c'est que je peux me
faire tout un système avec plein
d'enceintes Marshall différentes donc si
vous avez par exemple une Middleton et
que vous avez des petites Burton comme
ça à droite à gauche et vous êtes j'en
sais rien en train de faire un très
grand pique-nique mais vous pouvez
mettre de la musique un petit peu
partout et si vous êtes à la maison vous
pouvez laisser votre Middleton dans la
pièce principale et puis dans une
chambre vous mettez dans une autre
chambre ou une autre undertone ça vous
permet alors on peut faire un peu de
multiroom pas réellement mais en tout
cas on peut venir les utiliser pour
pouvoir diffuser de la musique à
différents points tout en sachant qu'ici
de toute façon on est déjà en stéréo
avec un vrai signal stéréo donc l'idée
quand même vachement cool alors on
n'aura pas la même image stéréoscopique
que si vous mettez une enceinte séparée
voie droite ou à gauche d'un côté et de
l'autre mais pour autant ça fonctionne
et je trouve ça très très chouette
puisque je vous montrais l'application
au-delà d'avoir ce mode stack
l'application et sa globalement pas
grand chose parce que ici vous voyez je
vais avoir mon égaliseur je vais avoir
mon mode stack un à propos ignorer
l'appareil l'égaliseur est bien en fait
on se parle ici juste des basses et des
aigus la même chose que je vais pouvoir
venir retrouver ici donc ce que je peux
venir faire ici voyez je peux venir le
faire directement là et ça s'agite
directement ici donc en fait ça me sert
pas à grand chose j'ai qu'à mes boutons
je peux venir régler directement là et
au-delà de ça et bien j'ai un à propos
ignorer l'appareil bon voilà il y a pas
grand grand nécessité à utiliser
l'application avec cet enceinte là
au-delà du mode stack et quand même très
cool il faut le reconnaître d'ailleurs
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en mode
dans les commentaires et d'ailleurs si
vous voulez vous balader on se
paraissait d'une enceinte qui fait 1 kg
8 c'est pas énorme donc vous voyez ça se
prend avec soi dans un petit sac pour
aller se balader très facilement après
il y a plein de petites techno à
l'intérieur vous avez la dynamique load
NES qui vous apportera un équilibre
tonal un équilibre au niveau du son bon
sur le principe je trouve ça bien ça
vient optimiser un peu l'histoire la
qualité sonore moi elle me convient
plutôt agréable ça fonctionne c'est
équilibré alors une fois de plus ça
dépend de chacun si vous voulez plus de
graves plus aiguë à vous de voir vous
venez le faire directement là
personnellement je me mets tout là comme
ça vous voyez à ce niveau à peu près
niveau hop là voyez je me laisse 4 bars
et 5 bars là hop là comme ça c'est assis
équilibré ça va dépendre une fois plus
du style musical que vous allez venir
écouter mais pour moi pour écouter du
rock ça fait le taf rock mais pas que
pour écouter autre chose pour écouter de
la fin que du RNB de la sole tout ce que
vous voulez surtout de la musique
classique et d'ailleurs c'est bien une
enceinte qui est faite pour l'extérieur
parce qu'elle est certifiée IP67 alors
derrière ce référence un peu barbare en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que vous
allez pouvoir la poser alors on va pas
lui faire prendre un bain de boue soyons
clair mais s'il y a un peu debout s'il y
a de la poussière s'il y a des
éclaboussures s'il y a un peu de flotte
qui tombe dessus ça va bien se passer
c'est cool vous inquiétez pas c'est une
enceinte est faite pour se balader
l'emmener avec vous elle doit vivre avec
vous et vivre la même big Boo donc si
vous voulez l'emmener dans un festival
bon là où il y a pas de musique dans un
coin un peu peinard et bien vous pouvez
si vous voulez l'emmener sur un road
trip en camion partir et vous posez sur
la plage avec ou sur des rochers vous
pouvez en plus elle est assez résistante
en tout cas elle me semble assez
résistante on va éviter de l'acheter
partout mais moi j'avais pris le lumber
tome 2 que j'avais emmené au Hellfest
d'ailleurs la vidéo est sur ma chaîne
youtube c'était bien passé donc il y a
pas de raison que ça se passe mal ici
d'autant plus à l'année à vous permet de
la transporter très facilement ça c'est
cool et puis vous partez loin vous avez
jusqu'à 20h d'autonomie 20h d'autonomie
alors l'idée c'est pas de venir elle
faire tourner 20h de suite mais ce que
ça montre c'est que vous pouvez la faire
tourner très facilement vous êtes
tranquille lorsque vous vous baladez
vous partez en road trip et au moment de
la recharger vous la brancher derrière
et une charge complète se fait en 4h30
et d'ailleurs un sujet marche à la fin
un truc hyper malin parce que vous
pouvez prendre ici votre Enceinte votre
Marshall Middleton pour venir recharger
votre Smartphone vous avez une très
grosse batterie à l'intérieur on peut
donc utiliser comme une power Bank
regardez ça se passe derrière vous venez
juste là et là vous voyez vous avez de
la place pour me débrancher alors
d'auxiliaire sur une entrée auxiliaire
avec un jack 3.5 si vous voulez venir
mettre de la musique directement dans et
que vous voulez pas utiliser le
Bluetooth bon pourquoi pas mais en plus
vous venez ici vous vous branchez et
vous venez charger directement votre
smartphone fait une fonction power Bank
vous prenez votre câble avec ici c'est
un iPhone alors vous allez avoir du
Lightning fatalement ici et de l'autre
côté de l'usb-c donc vous prenez vous
branchez l'usb-c dans l'usb-c très
logique d'ailleurs et le Lightning vous
le prenez vous le branchez dans votre
iPhone et là la magie opère qu'est-ce
qui se passe et bien votre iPhone se
charge oui c'est bon donc en fait votre
Enceinte Marshall n'est pas une enceinte
par sale c'est une power Bank on peut en
tout cas venir l'utiliser pour recharger
son smartphone et ça peut des fois
croyez-moi vous sauver la vie et autres
fonctionnalité qui peut être vachement
bien vous pouvez venir ici mettre deux
sources différentes si par exemple vous
êtes avec des potes vous êtes avec votre
smartphone et vous envoyez de la musique
depuis votre smartphone et puis que
quelqu'un d'autre veut reprendre la main
et bien il peut venir se connecter on
peut venir donc se connecter à plusieurs
ici sur votre Enceinte Marshall et une
fois de plus dans l'idée de la
convivialité avec des poches je trouve
ça plutôt bien et ici Marshall vous dit
votre enceinte est fabriqué à partir de
55% de plastique recyclés qui viennent
d'objets électroniques et tout ça sans
PVC donc il y a aussi derrière une
démarche écologique c'est plutôt bien et
on se parle c'est d'une enceinte qui est
disponible au tarif de 299 € sont les
gens design iconiques c'est la Marshall
Middleton qui vient compléter la gamme
aujourd'hui une fois de plus vous prenez
un Bertone 2 vous prenez celle-là elle
est quand même vachement plus grande et
on peut se faire plaisir avec tous ces
boutons et tous ces fonctionnalités donc
d'ailleurs dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser est-ce que vous aimez la
marque Marshall tout comme moi est-ce
que vous êtes client est-ce que vous
êtes amoureux de Marshall dites le moi
bien évidemment dans les commentaires on
se retrouve bientôt pour continuer à
parler d'audio à parler de Marshall
peut-être plus tard allez ça va mais en
tout cas de plein de nouveautés tech et
ça c'est vachement chouette donc je vous
embrasse dites moi tout ce que vous en
pensez une fois de plus dans les
commentaires et puis n'oubliez pas si
cette enceinte vous fait de l'oeil si
elle vous plaît et si vous voulez venir
l'acquérir pour les beaux jours et allez
vous balader avec vos potes et puis
faire des beaux pique-nique au bord d'un
lac pourquoi pas ou au bord de la mer à
vous de voir c'est votre vie ça vous
regarde et bien je vous mets le lien en
bas dans la description je vous embrasse
pour les soins de vous et à très bientôt
Ciao
[Musique]